is a concept about which we know
frighteningly little
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any of this
to happen
[Music]
[Music]
don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
why we tampered with the stability of
space time
the multiverse
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any of this to happen
[Music]
[Music]
wonder
i knew someone later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
i'm sorry steven
i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
[Music]
is you
things just got out of hand
[Music]
what's up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder where we talk
all things marvel and mcu and today we
got the official trailer for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness now
if you saw spider-man no way home in the
theaters and you stayed for the second
post credit scene you've actually seen
this before because the trailer was the
second post-credits scene for no way
home if you've seen it you know that it
is truly epic and now is the film that i
am most excited for that is up and
coming so let's break it down and don't
forget to subscribe if you want to stay
up to date on all of the latest mcu news
trailer starts off with a black screen
we hear ominous music playing in the
background and then we hear wong we hear
him say don't cast that spell it's too
dangerous now we didn't actually hear
wang say this in the actual movie but we
did hear him say it in one of the
trailers for spider-man no way home we
then hear dr strange say we tampered
with the stability of space-time we see
some candles blow out at the comartaj
and then we hear dr strain say the
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly little which is
exactly what he told peter in spider-man
no way home this implies that there are
severe consequences to what he did in no
way home that are now coming to fruition
in multiverse of madness this is also
demonstrated in the very next scene that
we get we see doctor strange's old watch
this is the one watch that he kept and
did not sell he had it the entire time
even after he became a sorcerer it was
broken and reflects the fact that he
himself was broken his hands no longer
worked and now we can see his reflection
in the watch in this post-credits scene
still shattered reflecting that he
himself is indeed still shattered and
the multiverse is now shattered as well
and unfortunately as the watch reflects
it is doctor strange himself who has
shattered the reality that he knows this
is further confirmed as we then hear
mordo say your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished if you recall in
the doctor strange film morda was kind
of devastated that the ancient one was
using dark magic in the film he says she
drew on its power to steal centuries of
life but she told them that it was
forbidden while she did that and then he
said the bill comes due it always comes
due which is now happening with doctor
strange and all of his actions the bill
is coming due including apparently what
he did in avengers infinity war and
avengers end game as the next part we
hear is doctor strange's line from
avengers infinity war right before he
snapped it was the only way referring to
him giving up the time stone now this
implies that there are a lot of things
here that are actually responsible for
shattering the multiverse hence
multiverse of madness it's not just what
happened in spiderman no way home but
it's also what happened in doctor
strange the first movie also what
happened in avengers infinity war and
end game after all the ancient one
explained in avengers infinity war in
2012 when hulk went back and talked to
her she explained that if you remove one
infinity stone from a universe that
would tamper with the flow of time and
that their world would be overrun and
millions would suffer without their
chief weapon against the powers of
darkness referring to the infinity
stones and this is actually exactly what
is happening right now the infinity
stones no longer exist in our universe
they were destroyed by thanos in fact
this is even a point that is made during
spider-man no way home when peter
originally goes to doctor strange and
asks him to reverse time dr strange said
even if he would be willing he doesn't
have the time stone anymore the chief
weapon against the power of darkness
that the ancient one mentioned we see
doctor strange go through a gate in
which new york seems to be kind of
falling apart this actually looks like
exactly what we saw in the what if
episode where doctor strange and stream
supreme were in what if episode iv
doctor strange bypassed an absolute
point in time this affected the universe
and essentially made it start going away
and eventually that universe did
completely go away it sort of dissipated
into nothingness which seems to be what
is happening right here now as far as
absolute points in time are concerned
doctor strange could have actually
bypassed several of them possibly
affecting infinite amounts of different
universes he gave up the time stone
which the ancient one did call their
chief weapon and even though infinity
war and endgame made it seem like it was
supposed to happen perhaps there are
some big consequences that follow up
with that plus not to mention his spell
did cause the sinister five to come into
spider-man knowing home and the main mcu
timeline doc ock green goblin electro
sandman and the lizard all have very
different fates now when they go back to
their own universes they were all
supposed to die or get locked up in a
prison however they are now cured and
they are back in their original
universes their fates have drastically
changed not to mention the fates of
their spidermans have changed as well
for example when norman osborne goes
back he's no longer going to be the
green goblin this will cause harry to no
longer turn into goblin and die this
will have huge implications on toby
maguire spider-man and that's just one
case alfred molina is going to go back
and his doc ock is not going to die as
well the repercussions of what happened
and spider-man no way home are going to
be huge and this is why doctor strange
is going to have to pay for them he
could have broken multiple absolute
points in time causing not only his
universe but possibly infinite amounts
of universes to start to collapse but
then a lot happens in this trailer we
see doctor strange enter a very dark
sanctum one that is flooded with water
we hear him say the words but i never
meant for any of this to happen he is
clearly talking to somebody that is
accusing him of being responsible for
all of this the fabric of reality
essentially melting now we could be
talking to wang he could be talking to
mordo or he could be talking to somebody
else there's rumors that the illuminati
could show up in multiverse of madness
and it's possible that they kind of
govern the multiverse and they could be
super pissed at him we see a shot of
wanda's hand using some chaos magic then
we see dr christine palmer walking down
the aisle and get this stephen strange
doctor strange is not waiting for her he
is actually in the pew the look on her
face as she walks down makes it seem
like she might have a little bit regret
of what she's about to do not mary and
steven strange and strange doesn't look
too happy as well but at the end of the
doctor strange film they kind of left
their own separate ways as friends we
then see a woman from behind wearing a
star on the back of her jacket this is
america chavez played by sochi gomez who
i actually met and had the pleasure to
talk to you for a little bit at the
shangshi and the legend of the tin rings
premiere now her powers are that she's
able to open up star portals to
different dimensions so this is kind of
a perfect movie for her to enter here
one where the multiverse is in madness
and it looks like doctor strange is
going to try and fix it america chavez
aka miss america is definitely going to
be a key asset we then see a very beat
up wong who looks like he's having a
rough time we then see somebody falling
through a portal of a shattered reality
and which i originally thought was
doctor strange but it kind of looks like
they have a ponytail here so maybe not
strange but if you look hard enough you
can definitely tell that that portal is
a star portal so it was created by
america chavez we then cut to the big
scene doctor strange goes and he finds
wanda she says i knew sooner or later
you'd show up and she starts talking
about the mistakes that she made in one
division in west view but dr strain says
i'm not here to talk about westview
wanna then ask what are you here for and
he says how much do you know about the
multiverse we need your help in which
wanda looks very surprised but we know
that wanda actually probably knows quite
a bit about the multiverse at this point
at the end of wanda vision in the
post-credits scene we saw the scarlet
witch astral projecting and learning
about other universes about different
realities because she was searching for
her kids we actually heard the doctor
strange theme music playing in the
background of this scene she was
searching the dark hold and actually
learning very dark magic all of course
to find her kids and what she finally
did here at the very end but since she
was using astral projection to study we
could probably assume that she's read
the entire darkhold which means that she
has been tampering with dark magic this
is something that mordo said was pretty
forbidden and even in a few scenes later
we see a picture of her as the full
scarlet witch we see her in the middle
of a seance surrounded by candles and
rumor has it that she is going to be
somewhat of a villain in multiverse of
madness now we're not really sure who
the main villain is at this point in
time but we do know that she really
wants to find her children and she has
been learning very dark magic so she's
going to be insanely powerful and she is
the scarlet witch now fully unlocked
which makes her even more powerful and
we know that she's probably going to
stop at nothing to find her children
even if that means having to fight
doctor strange but we'll have to wait
and see on that we then have a scene
where doctor strange comes out of a door
now the base of this door is kind of
floating in another reality it's hard to
tell what place this is but it could be
the home of america chavez the utopian
parallel the utopian parallel is a
dimension that exists in parallel to all
other dimensions of the multiverse it is
actually out of time and outside of the
multiverse as well we see strange
looking out of the door and behind him
we can see america's chavez and we can
see wanda we then see mordo and we hear
him say i'm sorry steven then darkness
and clouds go over the carmitage strange
and wong look insanely worried we see
the shots of the scarlet witch that i
talked about before and as we see mordo
and doctor strange fighting each other
we hear him say i hope you understand
and as he says this we see doctor
strange kind of casting some red magic
that looks an awful lot like wanda's
chaos magic and these little orbs kind
of look like perhaps different universes
different worlds all connected to each
other perhaps doctor strange trying to
do some damage control to what wanda has
done or he himself has done we then see
one of the villains of multiverse of
madness what we thought was going to be
shumagorth is actually gargantos now
i've spoken about gargantos before not a
very well known villain in fact he's
only appeared in a couple of comic
issues but is associated with neymar the
submariner of atlantis if the illuminati
is going to appear in multiverse of
madness it is possible that namor could
appear as well as he is part of the
illuminati this could explain how
gargantos arrives or they could simply
change the entire comic story altogether
and gargantos could simply be a
multi-dimensional villain it throws a
bus at doctor strange and america chavez
but doctor strange is able to protect
both of them by casting the spell and
cutting the bus in half then as we hear
mordo finally finish the sentence which
started off as i'm sorry steven i hope
you understand the greatest threat to
our universe is you and as he says this
we see an alternate sanctum which i'm
assuming exists in another universe or
perhaps in between universes in the
background it looks like this could be
some type of void i'm actually getting a
lot of loki vibes here when they finally
run into he who remains but here we meet
another doctor strange which could be
strange supreme we were introduced to
strange supreme in what if episode 4 and
also in the finale as well it is
possible that what if could connect to
the live action films however i'm
probably going to say that this is just
a different variant of doctor strange
which i think we might see a few of
these in the movie this one does seem to
be a lot darker and could be a lot more
evil we could probably assume that if
doctor strange is at the heart of the
multiverse breaking it's not just one
doctor strange but multiple ones and we
can assume that they're going to be some
evil ones and the trailer ends with this
strange saying things just got out of
hand and i don't know about you all but
i am super excited for this movie doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
looks like it's going to be phenomenal
don't forget to subscribe if you love
marvel and the mcu and want more content
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
you